il y à une frénésie exceptionnelle sur
l'action de tesla depuis quelques
semaines tesla fabricant de voitures
électriques l'action était à 418 dollars
en début d'année a frôlé les 1000
dollars cette semaine et ce soir à un
peu plus de 700 dollars que comprendre
de cette effervescence sur l'action de
tesla
à new york on retrouve pierre ferragu
chef de l'équipe de recherche en
infrastructure technologique chez new
street research bonsoir monsieur ferragu
moral comment expliquer la forte
volatilité sur l'action de tesla
alors c'est finalement très simple ça
reflète une réalité qui est très présent
ce qui est que les opinions sur la
société sur le stock sont très polarisée
il n'y a pas de juste équilibre sur
tesla pour certains c'est une société
qui construit des voitures sans aucune
expérience et qui a juste remplacé à un
moteur à explosion par une batterie à un
moteur électrique et donc à la aucune
viabilité
elles dépensent beaucoup d'argent elle
brûle beaucoup de cash
et donc elle va déposer le bilan et vu
pour d'autres c'est une société qui a
complètement réinventé la voiture de la
même manière que apple a réinventé le
téléphone en 2007 et ça fait dix ans
qu'ils travaillent sur leurs produits
ils ont accumulé une expérience
exceptionnelle ils ont un produit qui
est complètement unique qui est très il
ya une très forte dose de contenu
technologique et qui va donc gagner des
parts de marché et avoir une croissance
explique exceptionnelle pendant de
nombreuses années il ya quelques jours
sur 'cnbc' à new york vous avez dit que
le vrai bon prix en quelque sorte de
l'action c'est environ 800 dollars
pourquoi vous dites ça alors j'ai trois
convictions
à propos de tesla la première c'est que
ils ont un produit absolument unique
tesla a lancé le premier modèle s il ya
sept ans et depuis ils ont amélioré la
la performance de leur voiture de 40%
c'est à dire que l'autonomie de la
voiture en compte et en kilomètres ou en
mille a augmenté de 40% et c'est le
résultat vraiment d'un travail
exceptionnel de recherche de
développement et d'optimisation que ses
concurrents n'ont pas encore commencé
et donc il n'y a pas une seule voiture
conclure
de tesla qu'ils soient qui dépasse le
niveau de la première tesla donc tesla
et 40% devant sa concurrence donc ils
n'ont pas vraiment de concurrence la
deuxième chose c'est que le
développement du modèle 3 a bien montré
que tesla un marché adressable
extrêmement important si vous regardez
les personnes qui achètent un modèle 3
il faut aussi regarder les trade in les
voitures qui qu'ils apportent pour pour
remplacer par un modèle 3 40% de ces
voitures sont pas des modèles premium
sont pas des bmw se sont pas des
mercedes mais ce sont des toyota des des
ford est donc ça veut dire que tesla
adresse un marché qui est beaucoup plus
large que le marché premium et donc moi
j'estime que ce marché représente 20
millions d'unités par an donc tesla a
beaucoup beaucoup de demandes et peut
croître au taux autant qu'elle veut et
la troisième conviction que j'ai c'est
tout simplement que tesla a démontré
qu'il peut qu'elle peut que la société
peut produire ces voitures d'une manière
profitable et financer sa croissance
nous quand on combine ces trois
convictions ensemble on regarde dans
cinq ans qu'est ce qui va se passer
tesla produira 2 à 3 millions de
voitures à 45 50 millions d'unités
générera entre 15 et 25 milliards de
dollars des beats et donc ça veut dire
que le prix de l'action sur cet horizon
de temps sera entre 1500 ou aux
alentours de 1500 $ ce qui veut dire que
si aujourd'hui vous lâcher pour 800
dollars c'est un bon investissement et
donc c'est le bon prix et vous croyez
aussi que le véhicule est ce le véhicule
utilitaire sport
le nouveau modèle y électrique a
beaucoup de potentiel
expliquez-nous votre analyse là dessus
alors si vous regardez le marché le
marché du premium
ça fait maintenant presque dix ans plus
de cinq ans que le ces dames de la
voiture classique père du père du
terrain et se fait remplacer par l'ue
l'utilitaire est suivi qui gagne du
terrain et ce marché-là est suivi en
fait fait trois fois la taille du marché
de ces dames aux états unis et plus de
la moitié du marché en europe donc c'est
un marché que tesla
n'adresse pas aujourd'hui et donc avec
le modèle y tesla le augmentent très
largement la part de son marché
adressable que le portefeuille de
produits peut adresser la france et
l'allemagne développe en ce moment une
méga usine de fabrication de batteries
pour faire concurrence justement atteste
la est ce que c'est un danger pour tesla
ah non c'est pas c'est pas un danger
pour tesla et c'est quelque chose
finalement qu'on souhaite on ne souhaite
pas que tesla soit le seul fabricant de
voitures électriques tesla est un est un
fabricant de voitures premium et on
espère bien que des constructeurs plus
bon le grand public vont intervenir
aussi dans le dans le marché ce qui
différencie tesla vraiment c'est sa
capacité à avoir déjà investi dans une
telle usine il ya plusieurs années
quasiment 10 ans d'être capable de
développer les batteries développées la
chimie des batteries l'aller les
cellules des batteries le battery pack
qui est donc la manière dont les
batteries sont intégrés dans la voiture
et intégrée tout ça avec le système
électrique de la voiture qui transfère
l'énergie de la batterie dans le moteur
et qui transfère l'énergie dans la
batterie pour la recharger et cette
approche intégrée où tout est développé
à l'intérieur de la même société
c'est vraiment une caractéristique qui
différencie tesla et c'est ça qui va je
pense maintenir les voitures tesla à un
niveau bien supérieur à toute la
concurrence
très bien merci pour cette analyse
monsieur ferragui à new york ce soir
merci au revoir merci virale